jetzt meine damen und herren darf ich
ihnen die mitteilung machen dass wir
einen fahndungserfolg der bundespolizei
haben im falle susanne deß der im
zusammenhang mit dem tötungsdelikt an so
seine elf beschuldigte abb ist heute
nacht 18 juni 2018 gegen 2 uhr durch
kurdische sicherheitsbehörden im
nordirak auf bitte der bundespolizei
festgenommen worden
ich danke den beteiligten kurdischen
sicherheitskräften dass die diese
verhaftung möglich die diese verhaftung
möglich gemacht haben
dieser erfolg ist ein ergebnis der guten
zusammenarbeit zwischen den chaotischen
sicherheitsbehörden im irak und der
deutschen bundespolizei